لم تعد المنطقه الحدوديه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا امنه تماما الجانب الروسي من
الحدود يبقى في مرمى المسيرات الاوكرانيه
تتعرض لهجمات بشكل شبهي
غالبا ما تكون الاضرار الناتجه عن هذه
الاستهدافات محدوده حتى تلك التي تصل
العاصمه موسكو لكنها دون شك تنقل رساله من
كييف مفادها ان ضرب العمق الروسي لم يعد
مساله مستحيله وهذا ما يقلق روسيا
فالقدرات الهجوميه الاوكرانيه تدفع موسكو
الى تكثيف الاستعداد
لمواجهه هذه الضربات المركز الروسي
استراتيجي نشر تقريرا يكشف ان روسيا انشات
حقل رادار للدفاع الجوي في الاتجاه الغربي
من البلاد منذ مده طويله مهمته رصد
الاهداف التي تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه
والاهداف الصغيره كالمسيرات ونقل تقرير
المركز عن متخصصين ان الرادار الحديث
يمكنه اكتشاف الطائرات القادره على التخفي
على مسافه ثلاثه الاف كيلومتر واكتشاف
عمليات اطلاق صواريخ كروز او الطائرات
التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت على مسافه
تبعد الفي كيلو متر عن الحدود الروسيه على
مستوى التسلح استراتيجي كشف الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه الروسيه لبناء السفن
اليكس رخمه نوف ان الغواصه النوويه متعدده
الاغراض ارخان جيرس سيتم اطلاقها خلال
العام الحالي وهي من فئه غواصات ياس الامن
التي تعمل بالوقود النووي لتنضم الى ثلاث
غواصات من الفئه نفسها غواصات سيفيرو
دافيناسك وكازان ونوفو سايبر اسك وسيتم
تزويد جميع هذه الغواصات بصواريخ زيركون
الفرد صوتيه وهي صواريخ يصل مداها لنحو
900 كيلومتر ويمكن ان تتجاوز سرعتها سرعه
الصوت بعده اضعاف لتشكل بالتالي تحديا
كبيرا لامن الدول بسبب قدرتها على
المناوره وتجنب الدفاعات الارضيه
التقليديه في المقابل تستمر اوكرانيا
باعتماد استراتيجيه تستند على استنزاف
الجيش الروسي في نقاط تفوقه ضربات بعيده
المدى تستهدف بشكل خاص طرق الامداد
الروسيه والبنيه التحتيه للنقل العسكري
بالتوازي يقول المستشار في مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني ميخائيل بودالياك ان اي تصريحات
حول التقدم البطيء للجيش الاوكراني هي
دليل على الافتقار المطلق لفهم الحرب
ويضيف ان مهمه القوات الاوكرانيه تتمثل
بتدم ير منهجي بقدرات الجيش الروسي
[موسيقى]